citizens of the reject Nation this may already
be my favorite koi's comic Corner because this
is the one where I get to say a sentence I
never thought I'd say anywhere but my dreams
Hugh Jackman is coming back as Wolverine in
Deadpool 3 not only are we getting another
version another moment another experience
of Wolverine not only are we finally getting
Deadpool in the MCU but we're getting those two
beautiful babies together we are gonna make sweet
sweet Weapon X love with that logo we're gonna
dive into all of that we're gonna talk about
the possible plot I got some ideas of what this
might be we're gonna talk about what version of
Wolverine I think this might be because I don't
necessarily think it's one we've seen before I'm
gonna talk about cameos we could expect if it
is the plot that I think it is we've got a lot
of details a lot of breadcrumbs a lot of Easter
eggs leaning towards that Journey how that all
ties into the greater MCU going forward because
I do not think this September 24 release date
is a coincidence so please do leave a like on
this video leaving a like helps me know you
like this it's well named it's right there it's
got a thumbs up which makes me feel good about
myself also please do follow me on Tick Tock I
make a lot of videos over there I've made four
about this very subject but I haven't revealed
a lot of these thoughts yet because I wanted I
wanted to bring it to you first but I do a lot
of talking over on the ticks and the talk so
please follow me on Tick Tock helps me know
and well it helps the studios know basically
it's for the people I want the people to know
that you guys like follow me let's dive into it
all right so we're gonna start off with just
pure hype if I don't get this out of the way
now we will we will have a hard time later
on Hugh Jackman being back as Wolverine is
something I always wanted but didn't want and I I
know that sounds strange I wanted it but I didn't
in that Downey Jr Chris Evans and Hugh Jackman
I think are the three characters who are most
embodied by their actors that also had the best
complete arcs I would change nothing about the
journey we went on with Iron Man top to bottom
I would change nothing about how things landed
with Chris Evans in his entire Arc yes I would
change X-Men Origins Wolverine but I would not
change it at the cost of losing Logan and I think
that's how Hugh Jackman felt as well and that he
didn't want to lose the Integrity of how Logan
ended with the perfect swan song for his perfect
Wolverine I think the beauty of everything is now
we're living in a multiversal era we can have our
cake and eat it too and that we can have our Logan
and our Wolverine as potentially separate entities
so this is the only way I have no single regrets
about Hugh Jackman coming back there is nothing
holding me from being fully excited you give me a
buddy cop movie with a fish out of water Deadpool
a feral R-rated Wolverine you bring Hugh Jackman
back for one last ride this is exactly exactly
what we've only dreamed of and the Multiverse
brought us this as well as the timing of the
fox and Marvel merger now this video is going
to be in a slightly different order than the
usual comic Corner because much like Deadpool it's
confusing with continuity and it probably involves
cable and therefore time travel so we are going
to tease where I think they're going then we'll
get into the why and the details of how we got
there so at the top I'm gonna let you know at
the end I've seen your comments we will be given
comic recommendations I could do an hour on just
Deadpool comic recommendations but Greg was like
if you give them 76 recommendations they won't
read them and I did I sent him 76 recommendations
he was like cool you can do three and I was like
maybe four he's like no no three and he he runs
things he's just gonna edit it out so you're
getting some wrecks at the end so with everything
we know so far I do think this is going to be
pulling from the number one selling Deadpool comic
of all time which is Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe and I also think due to where Deadpool
2 left off with the Disney Fox merger with the
Multiverse established and The Saga this deep
into the Multiverse with the release date being
September a mere three months from 2025 with the
announcement of Wolverine with what the filmmakers
have said with the change of the writers with
the R rating with everything I think we've been
told this my dear viewers is going to be Deadpool
kills the fox Universe now you've probably heard
people theorize this before or something akin
to this a lot of people have theorized Deadpool
kills the Marvel universe as something that was
going to happen you want to check some tapes you
might notice a certain person in a chimichanga
shirt said about five and a half years ago he
was the first one he really thought Sandy had
it with Rob live felt the creator of Deadpool
so he might have been one of the first to say it
there's no way of knowing a lot of people have the
same great idea at the same time but I do know
I was one of the very first to suggest Deadpool
killing the fox Universe because I did talk with
Rob liefeld about it very very very long time
ago and then again we did talk about it in the
lockdown what's been interesting is I think this
story has changed and developed over the course of
time because the way this merger is gone I think
the best thing to happen to Deadpool one was
that Ryan Reynolds worked on it for 10 years I
think the best thing to happen to Deadpool 3 is
the fact that we had a fox Marvel merger happen
in the middle of a multi-billion dollar franchise
that is Deadpool only one character was getting
carried over while Marvel was simultaneously
setting up their Multiverse Saga and then the
world stopped I do think there might be a benefit
to this weird two-year Gap that coincides with the
five-year blip that coincides with one of the
biggest multimedia mergers of all time because
I honestly think we wouldn't have been able to do
Deadpool kills the fox Universe without the rights
expiring in 2025. so what I think is going to
be really interesting is this movie comes out in
September of 2024. this follows the Thunderbolts
Deadpool being a thunderbolt I do think that is a
perfect place for a post-credits scene perhaps
the first official Deadpool appearance in the
MCU being in a post-credits scene of thunderbolts
and it's really interesting because this not only
comes out after Thunderbolts again at that post
credit scene but this if you remember in that
giant lineup for phase six there were a lot of
spaces we saw Fantastic Four which appeared to
be the kickoff of phase six but there was a fall
2024 slot this movie right here may be the first
film the beginning the kickoff of phase six which
I do think is going to lead to a lot of mutant and
this is only three months only one movie removed
from them being able to cast mutants in the MCU
this is right there around the corner what better
way to kick off casting mutants in the MCU than
cleaning your slate and what better character
to do that with than the one that represents Fox
so cleanly who do you think when you think X-Men
I've said it before and I'll say it again I really
really enjoy the X-Men movies but they're Brian
Singer mutant movies we didn't really get a lot of
X-Men movies they also were Wolverine in the X-Men
movies all of that has been a point of contention
for me because I love me some X-Men as much as
I love Hugh Jackman's Wolverine again I think
he's one of the greatest casting choices of all
time I always wanted X-Men I think they're going
to learn that lesson and give us X-Men movies but
in the meantime when I think Fox when I think the
X-Men I think Hugh Jackman Wolverine so you've
got the perfect Pinnacle representing all that
is the fox mutant you've also got a character
that is a fourth wall breaking self-aware
only character up until she helped down the MCU
character that's aware they're in a movie aware
they're in something based off a comic the fourth
wall breaking mixed with Hugh Jackman coming back
representing all of fox cleaning the Slate for
2025 all of that timing lines up beautifully
and that is a huge reason I think they're going
to be doing this kills the fox Universe palette
cleanser for all of us in addition the writers
changing and getting Rhett Reese and Paul wernick
back I do think that might be them wanting to
do this from the beginning and getting that back
because of all these circumstances but also the
quotes about this being a fish out of water story
and a bromance now Sean Levy directed Real Steel
Ryan Reynolds good friends with Hugh Jackman I
think the combination once they brought on Sean
Levy a lot of us theorized that meant we could
get Wolverine Sean Levy said it as much that's
what he wanted saying quote what we want to do
is to fold it all in together and make a big fat
Bromance sandwich of the movie because the world
wants the Hugh Jackman Ryan Reynolds movie
he said that months ago I think it was the
combination of Ryan pestering you plus Sean Levy
coming back to direct with their relationship with
Real Steel I think that was the thing that finally
launched in and then the writers also said quote
it's a marriage between Fox and Disney it's two
different universes and it's not easy but it's
also a wonderful Challenge and you know high class
problems be able to merge those those worlds also
having said it's quote a wonderful opportunity for
a fish out of water story Deadpool is a lunatic at
the center of a movie to drop a lunatic into a
very sane world it's straight butter it's gonna
be really fun those are the quotes we had before
the Hugh Jackman thing was launched but locked in
those are the quotes we knew about the flavor of
this movie The the reason I think we're going to
get this combination of stories not just because
it's one of the best selling comics of all time
not just because it's a paling cleanser and
where it lines up in the schedule but because
I do think that gives you some closure to make
Deadpool R-rated so what I think this is going
to do is go back to Deadpool 2. it's going to
start with Deadpool in the fox Universe he's
going to be living his day-to-day life he might
be doing some time Turner hijinks I would love
for this to kick off right where the post-credits
scene did in that continuity in Deadpool 2 he's
using the time Turner to clean up a lot of fun
Ryan Reynolds he thinks he gets rid of Green
Lantern he gets rid of X-Men Origins Wolverine
he even fights a bygone Wolverine that's why I
think we're getting a different Wolverine than the
one in Logan in Logan we've got a perfect bow of
a story in X2 we could go back and grab that guy
and it'd be a displaced time Wolverine or we could
get a completely different variant Wolverine and I
guarantee you within five minutes Ryan Reynolds is
gonna make him put on that yellow and brown suit
I guarantee you because of this movie because the
Dynamics we're finally gonna get a comic accurate
Hugh Jackman Wolverine and I think that visual is
going to very much illustrate this isn't Logan
this isn't the Wolverine we've known for all
these movies it is still Hugh Jackman acting as
eyeballs out being the perfect Wolverine we've
always wanted but it's going to be very clear it's
not the Wolverine we've had and that's the beauty
of this Multiverse Saga it's all the things we
want but right over here without sacrificing
the Integrity of the performance and allowing
an R-rated Wolverine if you think about it as
far back as X2 the Berserker rage was still very
PG-13 they had to cut around it we then got Logan
we finally got the violence but now we get the
perverse humor of Deadpool mixed with the violence
of Logan all because we can make this a fresh take
on Hugh Jackman's version of Wolverine I think
that's what they're gonna do so I think we're
gonna go back to Deadpool 2 he's going to be using
the time Turner going through things maybe they'll
put that baby Hitler scene back in and we're gonna
be seeing a lot of fox cameos in the X-Men vein I
would love personally to see Anya Taylor Joy get
to play Magic one last time I would love to see
you know maybe two colossuses we have Cudmore as
well as the guy who played him in Deadpool I would
love to see some of the cameos that we got like
we did in Deadpool 2. throughout the opening
of this film and people are gonna go like oh
right Deadpool the audience is gonna think this is
Deadpool so it ties into X-Men we get that Comfort
we we feel nostalgic seeing I doubt Jennifer
Lawrence will come back but maybe we get nostalgic
seeing these characters pop back up in the realm
we're used to and that's the you know first 20
minutes and then while traveling through time I
think that's when he meets a different Wolverine
and maybe he doesn't recognize him there's a lot
of fun comic book story lines you could play with
there maybe they go to Alpha flight maybe we get
some original Weapon X stuff there's a lot to
play with there but then using those time travel
hijinks and setting up this new Wolverine it turns
into a them fighting before they Team Up movie
that is every comic book that is so many tropes
your characters have to fight before they team up
that's how it goes we've heard this is fish out of
water I think that's the third act in Marvel we've
heard this is team up buddy cop movie that's where
I think we get into the second act where now that
they've fought in a brutal blood-soaked R-rated
Battle of healing and Berserker rage we then see
them to team up and what I think happens is we
then meet Chris Evans and Chris Evans comes
up and you're waiting for either the shield
you're waiting for a moment of pure you know
Captain America Integrity maybe a speech maybe
he calls him James Howlett and you're expecting
like a World War II moment a throwback to when
they serve together and then he flames on and you
realize that oh right we're in the fox Universe
this bait and switch with Chris Evans and then we
have to take him out because we find out that an
incursion event is coming which has already been
set up in multiple movies especially most recently
the Multiverse Madness where an incursion event
occurs you have to take out one of the planets to
save the rest in order to save a Galaxy they both
die if they Collide but if you can take one out
you can save billions of lives there's an entire
storyline in the comic books called secret orbs
where basically there's an incursion of it where
these worlds are colliding and there's this super
group called The Illuminati which we also have
already met in the Multiverse of Madness they
were just set up in a different array basically
has to make these really hard decisions this is
all a precedent we've already met all this in the
MCU it would be very easy the especially after we
meet Reed Richards to have this Illuminati have to
decide they need someone to do the job no one else
wants to do Deadpool's a mercenary and Wolverine's
the best he is at what he does I think there will
be an opportunity for them to save more lives
Logan getting to keep his Integrity of having
to kill for all the right wrong reasons and
Deadpool enjoying being a mercenary he's got a
heart of gold but he's definitely a killer taking
out these characters I think starting with human
torch Chris Evans and then maybe going right into
Michael B Jordan's Chris Evans and then maybe we
get Nicholas Cage's Ghost Rider then maybe we get
Idris Elba and we think it's going to be heimdell
but then someone remembers oh right Idris Elba was
briefly in Ghost Rider too there's a lot of really
cool opportunity to play with expectations through
the second act of this film going into the third
Act of this film and we see us finally eviscerate
the fox Universe through one of the most bloody
experiences of buddy copton we could hope for
and then when Deadpool lands in the MCU maybe
either Wolverine has to sacrifice himself maybe
huge meets the new version maybe it's uh you know
a Daphne Keen reference maybe we don't actually
see Wolverine because remember they can't cast
him until 2025 we got three months to go maybe a
post-credit scene sets up the new Wolverine but
I do think there will be an ending that is the
passing of the torch and I think there will be
a very funny death of Logan I I think at this
time it'll end humorously I don't think they'll
kill him sadly twice I think Logan is the saddest
we'll get so they won't try to compete with that I
think there will be a humorous Death of Wolverine
setting up passing the torch very officially to
the new Wolverine to come starting three months
from then in 2025 and I think that is going to be
where we get into the Fish Out of Water Deadpool
scenario where he because he knows he's from
Another Universe because he's been tasked from
the MCU to take out the fox Universe because he's
been assigned aware there's multiple universes
that's how he can break the fourth wall in ours
that's how he can be the only R-rated character
that's how when you put Deadpool in the X-Men
later or The Avengers later or maybe even in the
Thunderbolt he swears it gets bleeped because he's
someone from another Universe our universe the
MCU the 616 they sometimes call it it's very messy
with continuities they count a lot of different
things one nine nine nine nine nine or six one six
that Universe can't handle an R-rated character
like Deadpool so that would bleep but in his mind
and in his movies he could still be R-rated so
when you fold him in put him in the MCU have that
fourth wall break have the awareness of the other
universes he just destroyed with Wolverine have
us finally get that team up we've always wanted
and have us clean up the continuity of all the
messiness of fox have that clean up Xavier being
in Multiverse of Madness have that cleanup Pietro
you know he's gonna kill a character named Ralph
boner you know he's gonna do it he's gonna enjoy
it you know all of that can get cleaned up very
beautifully and give us the mutant Saga to come in
2025 this starts phase six have it end 22 years of
fox continuity in Canon with the right characters
to do it have Hugh Jackman back as Wolverine have
Ryan Reynolds start his MCU tenure with Deadpool
kills the fox universe that's what I'd do it'd be
awesome let me give you some comic recommendations
so I said I'd give you guys comic recommendations
at the end in addition to of course Deadpool kills
the Marvel Universe it's written by Cullen Bunn
it is one of the most successful I think it is
to date the most successful Deadpool comic of
all time Deadpool goes around and has to kill
everyone in Marvel it is a very bloody good time
I would also recommend in that same vein after
it did so well they did a pseudo sequel called
Deadpool killustrated it is basically Deadpool
in every classic folk tale killing everything so
like he kills the way Lynn Moby Dick he kills Jack
of Jack and the Beanstalk and it's this really
beautiful stunningly Illustrated take of Deadpool
just mowing down all of your favorite fairy
tales and I think that could be something they
incorporate but it's also just a really good
comic and then finally all of this was about
Deadpool kills the fox Universe if they don't to
that story I want them to do my favorite Deadpool
Arc of all time I have two favorites one of them
is Spider-Man Deadpool team up we'll talk about
that in another video because that also might be
coming but my favorite of all time that's Deadpool
Centric without Spidey is is The Good the Bad
and the Ugly and that is a story in North Korea
where Wolverine Captain America and Deadpool are
doing a rescue mission at a concentration camp
for these these people that were were kidnapped
and and put in this camp and basically force-fed
Deadpool's DNA and they're rotting and mutating
and they're turning into different versions of
the X-Men and Wolverine and cap go way back to
World War II and then Deadpool is serious for once
there's moments of levity but it's a really dark
story that shows you the heart of Deadpool the
reason I like Deadpool 1 so much is you see that
Deadpool's a character that wears a mask to hide
his face to protect you from being grossed out not
his identity and this comic does that it shows you
the heart and the soul of Deadpool if they don't
do Deadpool kills the fox Universe I'd love to see
something like that with Hugh Jackman Wolverine as
well as Deadpool Ryan Reynolds maybe even Captain
America screw it bring back Chris Evans is the
one way I want Chris Evans back all right I'd
recommend The Good the Bad and the Ugly Deadpool
killustrated and Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe enjoy those Comics let me know what you
thought of them let me know what you thought of
this video let me know if there's anything in
this plot you want me spelled out more if you
want me to talk about some Spider-Man Deadpool
comics just leave a comment below let me know what
you thought of this idea and I'll see you next
time I can't believe this exists guys 2024 I'm
gonna be insufferable all nine months just talk
about this in fact from now on Good Luck Channel